[Music]
there are endless things to do in New
York City for the holidays and if you're
a Believer like I am that it is never
too cold for ice cream I'm Serendipity 3
to your list Chef Joe shows us two
treats that are sure to bring some
instant holiday cheer and a taste of
Christmas and every bite first up the
frozen hot cocoa ice cream sugar cookie
crunch is Sundae say that 10 times fast
so to the chocolate and caramel lines
last two scoops Sarah Japanese frozen
hot cocoa ice cream hot fudge chocolate
chips and sugar cookie crumbles now take
that process and repeat it twice and top
that off with fresh whipped cream Shea
chocolate a sugar cookie and a candy
cane next the rock hits gingerbread
frozen hot cocoa starts with a crushed
peppermint lime glass goblet filled with
their Blended gingerbread frozen hot
cocoa I'm going to top that with whipped
cream sprinkles of sugar flour plus our
favorite is gingerbread man waffle and
while you're busy shopping for everyone
else this is the perfect spot to treat
yourself and celebrate the holiday
season with friends let us know where we
should go next